they arrive at the outskirts of town at
a small Village Police are acting on
information provided to them by locals
and they want to move quickly
he says women to one side and in they go
they're always accompanied by a female
officer police are looking for anything
untoward
in some cases people don't have ID cards
and no registration papers
considering the circumstances we are
carrying out orders of our superiors by
conducting search and strike operations
for the sake of peace and safety in
hakimabad we've carried out house to
house searches and arrested eight to ten
suspects people who are not registered
we investigate them at the police
station people here are poor and there's
a transient population while some
officers search homes others stand guard
outside authorities here tell us since
there's been an increase of attacks
against police they're not taking any
chances these officers every time they
leave their base have to be armed move
in a convoy and be ready for any
potential attack against them
police come across a group of brothers
without papers or IDs they're taken away
for further questioning
we appreciate the efforts made by
policemen in conducting search
operations to find out if any militants
or criminals are hiding in our area
keeping in view the new surge of
violence in the country back at their
base police show us their equipment many
of it is old
some of us by our own bulletproof vests
says this is my personal vest
the Pakistani talibans say they've
carried out over 40 attacks against
security Personnel in January alone
these men say it's only a matter of time
until they're attacked
I said Pakistan